alors je le promène je peux aller faire
quelques courses et c'est lui qui me
guide d'accord alors il y a un endroit
d'ailleurs où il aime bien me guider je
dis très rapidement il y a un petit
beurre qui est très sympathique avant
rouge
et quand je lui dis on va au bistrot en
sortant de la maison je peux vous dire
on y est en deux temps trois mouvements
c'est génial c'était la Conférence
nationale du handicap à l'Elysée et ça a
dû faire un bien fou au président niveau
sonore
monsieur le Président de la République
Madame Brigitte Macron
et au nuque alors tu sais tu t'en rends
pas compte mais au nuque toi tu vas être
à la retraite à 8 ans alors que nous
hein
pas tout de suite comment ça va ou sinon
[Musique]
manifeste là lundi
1er mai
[Rires]
c'est 14h Trocadéro d'accord
autorisé puis interdit par arrêter
préfectoral et enfin tolérer les
casseroles sont beaucoup de bruit pour
accompagner les déplacements du
gouvernement ces derniers jours pour
parer d'éventuels restrictions des
internautes ont trouvé une astuce
enregistrer des bruits de casserole les
partager en ligne afin que les
manifestants les diffusent avec leur
smartphone l'idée a même été décliné en
site Ma casserole.fr il faut se faire
entendre c'est tout aujourd'hui
on sera avec les drapeaux français les
casseroles
puisqu'on a compris que c'était une arme
de destruction massive interdite par les
arrêtés préfectoraux donc manifestement
ça fait peur
il tape sur des bambous et ses numéros
dans son époux comme on est musicien il
faut quand on est musicien sur Radio
Jamaïque il a des copains
une femme avec sa musique et ça lui va
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi je fais la part des choses
d'ailleurs ce qui peuvent se permettre
qui ont le temps en pleine semaine en
pleine après-midi d'aller accueillir des
ministres pendant 4 heures de 14h à 18h
à priori c'est quand même pas les
Français qui travaillent qui ont des
difficultés au quotidien pour boucler
leur fin de mois pas sûr qu'on soit
toujours dans la même volonté
d'apaisement moi je croyais qu'on entrer
dans ce qu'on appelle la période de
l'apaisement des 100 jours d'apaisement
cette petite phrase du ministre des
comptes publics Gabriel Attal pas sûr
qu'elle soit là pour apaiser les esprits
apaiser les choses sa mission était
connue 100 jours pour apaiser le pays et
agir Elisabeth borne vient tout juste de
dévoiler son plan premier chantier
l'emploi et le pouvoir d'achat le
gouvernement veut bâtir d'ici le 14
juillet un nouveau pack de la vie au
travail pour améliorer notamment les
revenus et les conditions de travail des
salariés
j'ai pris un bon billet
c'est très bien payé c'est Amazon c'est
très bien mais j'ai pas trouvé ça cool
de sa part blanche parce qu'elle a fait
parce que ça jette un peu l'eau propre
sur nous tous nous autres genre nous on
est sur ceux qui l'ont fait genre en
mode et puis moi j'aime beaucoup blanche
on se connait pas on n'est pas pote mais
je pensais qu'on avait une bonne
relation quoi c'est que je me suis fait
engueuler là pourquoi non j'ai eu les
gens sur les réseaux et tout mais toi
mais toi de toute façon tu es à la salle
de d'Amazon toi de toute façon on fait
parler de la gueule avec de l'argent les
gars j'ai juste donné mon avis on a plus
le droit de donner son avis c'est quoi
ton avis ici tu peux donner ton avis
donne ton avis si je peux donner
ce que tu as fait comme tu es bête
[Musique]
bon allez on y va quel est le mode
d'emploi pour gouverner avec une
majorité relative et ça Elisabeth borne
avec comment dire toute la bonne volonté
de la terre ne pourra pas tout à l'heure
donner les clés de ce mode d'emploi et
au fond elle en est réduite à espérer
que
ce cabotage c'est à dire cette façon
d'essayer d'aller trouver des textes
d'aller trouver des majorités au cas par
cas bien lui permettre de de tenir donc
de ce point de vue là les 100 jours ne
seront pas conclusifs ce sera plus
encore une fois une façon d'essayer de
gagner du temps deuxième priorité
accélérée la transition écologique un
projet de loi sur l'industrie verte sera
débattu au Parlement avant l'été la
première ministre a aussi rappelé les
annonces déjà faites pour une meilleure
gestion de l'eau et des forêts qu'il ne
faut pas chercher à attiser les colères
aujourd'hui il faut apaiser le pays
le gouvernement améliorer l'action je
vous voyais hocher la tête un peu
négativement
sera un bon conseiller de la première
ministre bien vu les enjeux il a bien vu
il a bien vu les enjeux
oui
la journée est finie pour Benjamin
Duhamel
IE
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs j'ai pourquoi je suis pas
gratuitement Canal+ d'ailleurs monsieur
c'est Cyril Hanouna
bien sûr oui sans déconner oui oui sans
déconner c'est moi je suis en direct
ça nous faisait passer nous un petit peu
pour des gens pas bien je dis écoute tu
es pas tu peux dénoncer parce que c'est
il y a deux choses il y a refuser
l'émission et dénoncer le le tout ce que
représente Amazon le système tout ça
Jeff Bezos moi ça machin machin ok c'est
deux choses complètement différentes
mais soit tu dis rien sinon on prend
l'oseille donne-le à des associations tu
vois tout mais tu peux voilà il y avait
une plaque de marbre à l'origine
d'accord donc vous êtes peut-être pas
obligé de le dire au marchand que vous
allez rencontrer tout à l'heure mais il
y avait une plaque de marbre à l'origine
vous voyez vous êtes en train de devenir
filou qui est déteint sur vous
c'est quoi votre prénom c'est quoi votre
prénom
de dire que tu seras viré parce que
19h11 on
dirait François
Bon bah tu as un amour mon chéri est-ce
que tirer sur une saison 3 ouais pour
combien pour combien tu veux combien
on négocie là vas-y dis combien tu veux
c'est toujours dispo les 200 cas ou pas
alors du coup comme elle a refusé